siyeong Bumba and her cohorts are
planning what they call a culture raid
their target for debe Kira is a former
Ghanaians culture minister and music
manager the women want to direct his
attention to their activities at the so
Leo Academy cyan bomba wasn't exactly
invited this day but she arrived anyway
I have nothing other than my voice and
my songs that's a choice I made I did my
studies but I was never able to work in
my field my aim is to speak on behalf of
women whose voices are never heard thats
what inspired Salem Bamba to launch her
initiative to promote young female
artists she has no work space for them
yet so everything's improvised Bamba
wants to help these women develop their
potential and empower them to discuss
issues usually considered taboo such as
sexuality and female genital cutting
there are things that are important to
us and the younger generation things we
need to address here in Conakry let's
talk about them sensitivity of our
bodies is not something that was created
by someone it's something were born with
anyone who wants to cut a girl has to
know there's a vital part of her body
that's being taken away from her sian
bomba also acts as a coach for young
women her role resembles that of a big
sister two weeks ago one of the women in
her Academy had a baby but her partner
left her and now she's a single mother
don't believe on men just aren't there
that's what's so terrible we need men to
be more responsible women want men to
take more responsibility and use condoms
without our having to tell them to as
soon as a baby's on the way they
disappear say ol Bamba has plenty of
experience on that front she has three
children and is raising them alone but
she still developed a career in the
music business
that was only possible with talent a
good education and support from others
another goal of her Academy is to
support and encourage participants
beyond music you're still young
you're gonna don't make the same
mistakes we did my baby's not going to
stop me when she cries I'll take her
with me I'm going to stay in the Academy
with the other women I haven't lost
heart do what you really want and don't
give up
that's Ione bombas philosophy